[Música]
bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días magazine
informativo dedicado al continente
africano
comenzamos con los titulares
39 meses más de tres años es el plazo
que comunicaron las autoridades
militares de guinea para devolver el
poder a los civiles así lo ha anunciado
el jefe de la junta mamá ya tumbó ya
desechando las reclamaciones de la
comunidad económica de estados de áfrica
occidental
en sudán la región de darfur en el
occidente del país vuelve a ser el
escenario de masacres más de 200
personas fueron asesinadas en 4 días de
ataques que comenzaron el viernes 22 de
abril nuestra corresponsal en la región
nos dará los detalles de lo ocurrido
y 50 años después de su muerte qué es lo
que nos queda del legado del héroe de la
independencia de ghana y del
panafricanismo kwame nkrumah le
planteamos la pregunta a ansa tu booker
y historiador y autor de una biografía
sobre el ex presidente gane
un duro revés para los partidarios de la
democracia en línea y para parte de la
comunidad internacional el jefe de la
junta militar mamá de dumbo ya anunció
el pasado sábado que la transición antes
de entregar el poder a los civiles sería
de 39 meses es decir más de tres años
con este anuncio de un goya desafío a
los socios regionales del país que le
habían pedido un plazo de seis meses el
oficial que derrocó al ex presidente
alpha condé el pasado mes de septiembre
se autoproclamó desde entonces jefe de
estado con el apoyo de gran parte de la
población harta de la pobreza de la
corrupción y la represión bajo el
régimen de conde pero a finales de marzo
de este año la comunidad económica de
estados de áfrica occidental cedeao
había pedido a las autoridades de
conakry un calendario de transición de
seis meses su pena de prorrogar las
sanciones económicas decididas contra el
país tras el golpe sin embargo al igual
que en mali burkina faso 2 otros países
de la región donde los militares tomaron
el poder la junta guineana parece hacer
poco caso a las exigencias de la
organización regional escuchemos a mamá
y don goya
de tutela concentración de azul a nivel
de todas las consultas realizadas a
todos los niveles desde el inicio de la
transición con todos los miembros de la
nación con todos los guineanos donde
quiera que estén ha surgido una
propuesta media de duración consensuada
de la transición de 39 es condición de
tal
luciana de el comité nacional de la
agrupación para el desarrollo y el
gobierno presentarán a su vez esta
propuesta fruto de amplias y pacientes
consultas al consejo nacional de
transición que actúa como parlamento en
base ante concertación vamos a darfur la
provincia más occidental de sudán donde
el viernes 22 de abril iniciaron varios
días de violencia en los que más de 200
personas fueron asesinadas el conflicto
en esta región es antiguo y se presenta
como una oposición entre tribus árabes y
tribus africanas pero fue principalmente
alimentado por el régimen de la antigua
autócrata sudanés omar al-bashir contra
quien la corte penal internacional
y una orden de detención por crímenes
contra la humanidad los detalles con
marian con en nuestra corresponsal en la
región
comenzó hace una semana cuando
combatientes árabes armados atacaron las
aldeas más salido una migraña étnica en
represalia por la muerte de dos de sus
miembros el conflicto que comenzó en la
aldea de krenek alcanzó su punto más
violento el día 24 de abril con 231
muertos y 13 heridos según el gobernador
de darfur occidental que acusó a las
fuerzas gubernamentales de haberse
retirado sin ninguna justificación y de
haber dejado
desprotegida la comuna de crédit que
ahora está completamente destruida
siempre según el gobernador del estado
que denunció crímenes contra la
humanidad estas violaciones son una
nueva escalada en el conflicto de darfur
que empezó en 2003 entre las fuerzas del
régimen militar islamista del ex
presidente omar el bashir y las
rebeliones de las comunidades entre
ellas los más sal y que se sienten
marginales
desempleadas en el momento más violenta
por la lucha contra contra los rebeldes
las milicias armadas llamadas janjaweed
compuestas principalmente por nómadas
árabes de se emplearon un papel
importante en la represión las
violaciones y las operaciones de crear
operaciones de limpieza étnica llevada a
cabo por el jefe militar islamista de
omar al bachir en tren y que según
varios testigos estas ministras
volvieron a actuar en los últimos 20
años los enfrentamientos en darfur han
dejado más de 300.000 muertos y casi 3
millones de desplazados hace 50 años
nkrumah el padre de la independencia de
ghana murió al igual que el burkinés
thomas sankara o el congoleño patrice
lumumba kwame nkrumah fue considerado
como la encarnación del panafricanismo
el líder quería hacer de áfrica un
conjunto unificado como los eeuu de
américa
es su trayectoria
tuve los planes a ese experimento una
áfrica fuerte y unida
nkrumah era doctor en teología y
licenciado en filosofía
antes de fundar en 1949 el partido de la
convención y llamar a la desobediencia
civil contra los colonizadores las
autoridades coloniales británicas lo
encarcelaron consagrando el comienzo de
su ascenso político en 1951 su partido
ganó las elecciones y su liberación fue
un triunfo popular en las calles de la
capital de ghana accra en menos de una
semana nkrumah cambió su uniforme de
convicto por un traje de primer ministro
de un gobierno autónomo cinco años
después en unas nuevas elecciones
generales consolidó su poder obtuvo tres
cuartas partes de los escaños y obligó a
londres a conceder la independencia del
país en
1957 la costa de oro terminó y el país
fue rebautizado gana en homenaje al
imperio de ghana
esta es una imagen de la reina isabel en
accra en 1961 pero las relaciones con la
corona británica se deterioraron
rápidamente
como presidente kwame nkrumah se acercó
al bloque del este a la unión soviética
y también a china lo que convirtió al
líder en un adversario para gran bretaña
pero la preocupación también empezó a
crecer en gana ya que muchas de las
voces disidentes fueron silenciadas
nkrumah fue víctima de al menos cuatro
intentos de asesinato en octubre de 1965
recibió en accra a la mayoría de los
jefes de estado africanos de la
organización de la unidad africana esta
fue la última vez que tuvo la
oportunidad de presentar su proyecto
para africanista áfrica debe unirse con
el mismo como líder lo que provocó la
desconfianza de sus homólogos
anticolonialista ferviente fue derrocado
por un golpe militar en
1966 cuando se dirigía a china y
encontró refugio en la guinea del
presidente sexto interés
finalmente en 1972 murió en rumanía
lejos de su país y de su cortina
hablamos con amsat booker y historiador
especialista en panafricanismo sobre lo
que queda en el continente de la
ideología de kwame nkrumah medio siglo
después de su muerte
50 años después de la muerte de guam en
coma mucho queda de su lucha por un lado
su ideología panafricanista sigue siendo
pertinente con la idea de que es
importante que áfrica se una y
establezca unidad en la cuestión de la
defensa la moneda y del desarrollo me
llaman también es relevante para las
diversas luchas que se libran hoy en día
en áfrica y en la diáspora
ya sea la lucha contra el racismo y la
lucha contra otras formas de
colonialismo que él mismo mencionó en su
libro el neocolonialismo última etapa
del imperialismo en cuestiones de
identidad que abordó en su libro el
conciencia en el que se interesó por la
noción de la personalidad africana gruma
sigue siendo un ejemplo del líder ya que
fue el primero en llevar a su país a la
independencia quien trajo la diáspora y
el panafricanismo áfrica quien trajo
símbolos como la estrella negra de
marcus garvey así como la figura de
william tuvo quien de alguna manera
encarnó la forma más completa del
panafricanismo político también podemos
decir que como presidente de ghana dejo
a este país diría yo un adn
particularmente interesante desde el
punto de vista de la ideología política
desde el punto de vista también de la
fuerza de las instituciones pero además
de la apertura al continente y al resto
del mundo así que hoy nkrumah es
reivindicado por una parte de la
juventud que no está suficientemente
estudiada y planteada políticamente
porque la unión africana no se ha
adherido a su visión de los estados
unidos de áfrica pero sigue siendo desde
el punto de vista de las luchas
políticas sociales y económicas uno de
los mayores teóricos de la lucha
política africana y también uno de los
ejemplos de un gobierno panafricano
podemos para fitur en sujeto un suburbio
popular de las afueras de johannesburgo
en sudáfrica una residente también
mazibuko está detrás de la iniciativa
del suelto book café una librería para
avanzar en la alfabetización y
proporcionar a toda la comunidad un
acceso a los libros veamos
detrás de la puerta de esta casa en una
calle de soweto un barrio popular de los
suburbios de johannesburgo se encuentran
paredes llenos de libros es la casa y
librería biblioteca de tam y más dibujo
cuando terminó la escuela también dejo
soweto y se mudó a un suburbio blanco de
johannesburgo donde vivió en una casa de
artistas llena de libros se convirtió en
un lector ávido y poco a poco fue
creando una colección personal que se
llevó consigo cuando se trasladó de
nuevo a soweto
soy un ávido lector cuando volvía aquí
en 2015 o 16 no había ninguna librería
costos de todo eso aeg live hecho estaré
feliz así que se me ocurrió la idea de
crear este espacio para la comunidad es
la plataforma
empezó entonces el soweto book café hoy
está me vende libros a quienes pueden
pagarlos y los presta a todos los que se
lo piden
esta es una de las razones por las que
puse en marcha este lugar para promover
la literatura la alfabetización y
proporcionar a la comunidad el acceso a
los libros y la información que son un
derecho humano las pequeñas librerías de
barrio como estas han tenido mucho éxito
durante el confinamiento por el hobbit
19 la librería de tammy está llena de
libros de segunda mano y le gusta
especialmente centrarse en la literatura
africana organizando a veces
lanzamientos y lecturas pero sobre todo
su espacio ofrece un lugar seguro para
los jóvenes del barrio
les proponemos cerrar esta edición con
la banda nigerina estudio 75 músicos que
combinan instrumentos tradicionales con
música electrónica gracias por
acompañarnos y las noticias siguen en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
mira